whoa
look at all this luggage where are we
going monkey cheeto mojito
hawaii
is that your hawaii dance
do you even know where hawaii is mister
don't think it matters
mama do you think he knows where hawaii
is
what do you mean it's one of our
favorite places to
go oh
of course he's gonna smack him with a
blanket
hey someone's pushing his luggage
different than the way we're doing it
[Music]
you do have four wheels
but if you pull like this it might be
easier mister
i'll do it a different way okay i'm
gonna do a different way
okay
okay mister
whoa
look at all this luggage
cuny sand toys
monkey where are we going
is that your travel dance
[Music]
grandpa loves him so much oh look at his
eyes my dad never looked at me like that
how come he never looked at me like that
i mean because you look like that
so
we had our first travel hiccup already
we we used a lot of people
and i did oh okay so last night when i
got home it was already like midnight
and i was trying to book an uber so that
uh they can come and take us to the
airport and i guess it probably already
crossed the next day so it goes like
would you like to book for tomorrow and
yeah of course tomorrow
and then so we're standing outside
waiting for the uber to come and i'm
like oh man they're usually not not this
late and then i was like looking i kept
looking at my phone i was gonna message
him but then that option wasn't there
and i was like wait what's going on and
then it says that they were supposed to
come tomorrow and i'm like oh
so no
because then um
now we have to have to figure out a way
to scramble to get to the airport and
then so i'm like
mom is like we should just drive and i'm
like yeah that's true let's just drive
so
we're here driving ourselves to the
airport and i'll just be parking my car
there for like a whole week well
initially we said your dad and you're
like oh i don't know he's new here i
don't know if he'll be able to get his
way back
yeah because the airport is kind of
confusing um i would be more comfortable
if i already drove him through the
airport i showed him these are where all
the exits are because he also doesn't
really read english that well
and he's used to the lax but just not
this one
at the lvx
yeah exactly
hey duty we gotta go fast so we don't
miss our flight okay
exactly you got everything strapped in
all right judy let's go
oh that's so fast rudy whoa you're
beating mama
whoa that's too fast
good job
go monkey go
hey monkey who packed a little booshie
for you on the side like that
that's so cutie pies
by myself
oh i'm so proud of you
it's the yeah
i know it's literally the cutest thing
in the world to see right around this
little backpack
nowhere now we go to the right
uh it should be a hawaiian
good
job thank you for being such a good
hustler little monkey
sauce
he's so good
you're such a good traveler
you want to lift up your own luggage
okay let's see
that's what it says
you lifted a hundred pounds
monkey you lifted a hundred pounds
that's crazy bounds
that's not a hundred wow you're a big
boy you do your own stuff you're gonna
go that way that way this way duty you
go first
wow you big boy
you can push it open he doesn't even
need to push it
so glad we made it mama
why because i i honestly thought i was
like it's like i didn't want to show
panic but i was like i think we may not
make it actually because it was just
right there like everything got pushed
back there's that car accident on the
freeway and then there's the uber so
like i do a lot for an extra um
hour but all those things like took up
like 45 minutes
a little bit sad that you didn't give
him knuckles
here's knuckles i'm sorry i'm working
just as well
you're the true hustler and you're the
big boy traveler
okay let's go let's go
it's my favorite it's my favorite right
here
[Music]
hey monkey you gotta hold on okay
[Music]
we gotta go to our gate
good job duty
what are those things called again
good job
what's feiji in english
what about feiji and spanish toto
now you're gonna go on the fake g
we're going to walk through that little
tube over there yeah good job going to
walk through that tube you see that tube
right there
we're going in the little tube now
mama's got sucked into the tube
i'm so proud of my boy he's such a good
traveler now he's been to taiwan japan
all these cool places hawaii before but
then he didn't really know what's going
on and now he really does and he's such
a fun guy to travel with yes monkey
oh yeah oh yeah it's grippy
got a little bushy a
he's ready to go
good job
here comes another one
oh look monkey you can see the airplane
you see that yeah you could touch the
outside look touch the outside look
monkey
hey monkey we made it we're in our seats
good job
so cuny look at a little cutie little
set up right here
three locations
you put your seatbelt on already too
you're a good traveler really really
good
of course he wants next
yeah
like the one we brought from the car the
big ones
that's underneath the airplane
yep
look how cute this is this guy's whole
body fits in the chair it's like it's
bed here let me see put your leg right
here
good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome aboard hawaiian airlines flight
seven
monkey what do you have there
they just give you coke
yeah what did you say
well how did they know that you wanted a
coke what do you tell them
please
yeah she said do you want somebody to
drink and then what do you say
can i have soda
they give you soda on the plane
is that cool or what
you like this give a little thumbs up oh
you got a thumbs up
thumbs down
it's a mixed review mixed review
we made it
what a good traveler dude i'm so proud
of you mister
yeah how does it feel it still feels
like an airport huh yeah just that
little bit through the tunnel was pretty
humid yeah um because that was really
like oh yeah
and i used to i know wearing a hoodie
too yeah well the airplane was really
cool
danny i'm so proud of him he's traveled
so good yeah he's he's the man he's a
travel man traveling six hour flight
like nothing buddy
hey monkey
do you know what this thing next to you
is for
mover
for what
good job that's smart
when the luggage comes out you have to
help us find it okay
do you remember what mama and papa's
luggage looks like and what yours looks
like
yeah
good job
[Music]
yep it has wheels
you're looking at the food list that
david said
it's good huh it's not fat for no reason
yes
oh yeah it does look like that
i'm kind of feeling katsu you know for
katsu no i want udon oh dawn i love udon
dude you're gonna break my arm are you
kidding me
how did you go from sitting on the
ground attacking me
oh
that's your favorite
udon
what that's the first time you didn't
get excited for udon
what if it starts going it takes you
away
okay
hey look hello
matching crocs
that's cutie pies
yeah i got matching crocs
are you copying me are you copying me
you know what that sound means
that means not look for it
where does it come out comes over here
over there
[Music]
are you paying attention do you see any
of them
you see it
and the traffic jam
hey all three of them right there
you found them
oh no i got stuck in there
there we go
here comes you gotta help mama okay
here it comes
there it is
hey that's someone else's suitcase don't
touch it
all right you gotta help mama there it
is
you're so little he's so little huh
somebody
yours is coming you can do yours that's
your size
all right here it is
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do
good job whoa
good job
wow that was awesome dude
our first
breath
of fresh air
hawaiian air how does it feel mama
like i've been missing this for so long
like three years i know
good job you are such a good traveler
every single step i look and you're
doing the right things
you show me
whoa holy moly that's incredible
oh that's strong
the breeze feels awesome huh it does
it feels great my hair already is trying
to curl because it's okay you feel it
really i mean i could just feel it in
the air not my hair
but i just know what's about to happen
because i'm like oh [ __ ]
my hair loves this [ __ ] it's about to go
we made it
we've been wanting to come for such a
long time
you always leave him hanging what sorry
what is it mister oh hi
we're a trio and what's cool is the last
time we came here this guy was like
semi-coherent not really there yet yeah
yeah now he knows what's going on he's
gonna have so much more i can't wait is
this us yep uh hurts yep
let's go let's go duty
you never been on the bus before
well it's your first time duty
are you sure maybe you're just too young
to remember
no okay i trust you
okay i trust you then
thank you sir
one part of the traveling experience
that i always forget about when coming
to hawaii is if you're renting a car
there's always a long ass line to get
your car
because everyone else has the same idea
so you're gonna wait at least an hour to
get your car so i'm like hyped that we
landed yeah there's cool movement and
then we go
stop because we have to pick up a car so
keep that in mind
before you get hyped like me like i do
every single time i land here i have to
pick up a car
all right so i just went through a bunch
of drama at the front desk of car rental
long story short
i booked this whole trip three four five
i didn't even maybe five months in
advance because i just know me and joe
workaholics and if i don't book
something in advance we're never going
to go on vacation and i think it's super
important not only for our own mental
health but also to spend some really
cuny intentional time with taika so i
really wanted to book a family trip
especially since we uh haven't done one
a long time because you guys know the
pandemic right it's hard to go on trips
and stuff so i book it i get there i go
here's my reservation or my confirmation
number they look all over for like 30
minutes by the way i stood in line for
like an hour because it's freaking
popping here
and uh they couldn't find it i'm like
what do you mean like i when i booked
the the
the rent the car rental a few months ago
i quadruple checked all my emails like i
like to make sure everything's set in
stone and i forget it right
and then they did another check and like
oh you know what it's actually at the
other hertz and i'm like this airport
has two hertz that doesn't even make any
sense that how confusing is that and i'm
like how far away is the other hurts
they said the other hurts is a 20-minute
walk on my dude i got a family of three
we got tons of luggage there's no way
we're gonna walk
for um 20 minutes i was like what can
you do for me now and they go we
actually have this manager's special i'm
like i love the way that sounds because
i'm always trying to do things on a
budget and do it for a good deal i'm
like give it to me what is it
you know like we got a chevy spark i'm
like i don't even know what that is like
it is kind of small i'm like i don't
care i think it ended up being like
under 100 bucks a day or something like
that i was like that sounds amazing
put me in the chevy spark and here we
are in the chevy spark
and look at my bear
look at my bear's big ass
no watch
walk out stand out stand outside
are you
sure this is some [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] clown you're in a clown car
hey but everything fit look at all that
we got all the luggage we got the little
munchkin back there we can get our buddy
back or whatever for the other car yep i
know i gotta call him
why would you do that hawaii why would
you play this like i don't know why
would you have two hertz for even though
it was popping pogba
mindful is my fault
all right you gotta get back here see
you crazy guys
all right fine we're gonna have an
awesome time
so yeah the other car was gonna get
the other cars
um it was also economy
so i don't know if the other one would
have been better than this one
and i wasn't familiar with what the
chevy spark is but now i do
is someone copying me
[Music]
[ __ ] that's crazy bones hey my name is
tyke i'm a big dumb dumb
my name is jacob
yeah
yeah
it looks nice
really it looks nice in there well i
don't know whoa
that's fancy
do you want to get your bag
no i'm gonna check out the hotel first
whoa
wow look at that hey there's a stuffy in
here
[Applause]
this is nice this is really nice that's
awesome see i told you if you roll with
me and live the good life i tricked you
i tricked you with the car
and then i got a little ocean front view
oh oh
damn plan
so is standard right look which one this
yeah pretty standard okay
open it open it can you open it oh look
at this look at this
hey monkey i've never seen a monkey
there's a pool down there yeah oh that's
a nice little pool
i know he sees a pool but there's an
ocean there he's like
that's so funny holy crap
wow
he wants to stand on the chair are you
kidding me dude
we do have a way i don't even think that
pool belongs to ours
where right here
where
that's so scary
oh my god are you kidding me
holy crap
that is so scary
wow look at that
that's an amazing view
yeah
no i think the ocean's not as big as the
pool the ocean is huge it goes off
forever
well technically not forever
all right so i got so
all right so i got so excited right
outside because the view was insane this
is so nice we get like a little um
kitchen kitchenette over here and then
the bathroom wow
this is cool look at that
wow
open shower
did something just missed
oh the bidet are you serious
oh what
oh yeah it is a bidet
damn plan
they got a bidet in here do you know
what it is
a shower in the bathroom
together
that's cool huh
tyka what are you about to do
from there all the way to there are you
kidding me
whoa
wow you're a daredevil um
i don't have to see it again but i have
a feeling you want to show me
okay let me see
[Music]
oh you're on my thomas
okay
what a big coincidence
so one of the bomb udon places we wanted
to try is in this plaza called royal
hawaiian and in the royal hawaiian is
also
where the new juvi's gonna be
oh that's kind of blown out let me see
there we go
that's so cool
and what's awesome
is this store
is right
facing the street
so you're gonna get lots of visibility
lots of foot traffic from all over from
this whole building
that's amazing this is a great location
that's a great location huh mama
what do you think taiko i think is a
good location
let me see let me see what you got
whoa i saw you practice that in the
bedroom
good job duties
are gonna jump in the water
does it make you nervous to see them
play around like that yes
jump on the rocks i grew up with extreme
nose
you get get over there get over there
get over there get over there you saw
shaky knees yes get over there you know
that's how boys play right we jump on
rocks and stuff yeah but i up like this
i grew up with extreme rules and like we
follow everything and like everything's
just
we're gonna step on that grandma okay
monkey come here
uh-oh
too much
so i think sometimes it's good to have
fun
we gotta know the boundaries i think
taika almost did something that was
really bad i don't know what it is but
it's dad time
all right so i'm really excited about
this place because as you guys know
david soh
loves food and
he is a certified expert of hawaii
because he comes so much
i did
as his brothers
and uh when we came here when i was gone
on the plane i texted i'm like yo give
me a list of must tries in hawaii and he
said
one of them is uh
udon
which is freaking awesome because we all
know that this little dude
this chilling little dude loves udon
oh oh oh oh
oh
you were relaxing what is going on you
were relaxing now you come beat me up
and me and mob are about to get sexy in
about two weeks so this is probably one
of the last times you can have like a
bowl full of delicious carbs and a
delicious yummy broth so i'm really
excited about this place because they
got all kinds of like beef udon curry
deluxe pudding chicken udon
so usually whenever i go to a place i
always ask for the number one right
that's usually that restaurant like
flagship thing for some reason the
pseudo tone deluxe mudan isn't
speaking my name
and i usually judge udon spots
based off the ogb photo but seeing that
they also got a wagyu
shabu udon i'm like is this
that but on steroids what are you gonna
get so i'm between
the beef udon which is the
udon looks pretty pretty good
and then the sashimi
the nabayaki is like the og sumo
wrestler udon um if you like one a
lighter broth i would go with this one
if you want like a deeper body broth
and then this is the deep deep body
sesame oil
oh yeah that's lots of flavor with that
one
so many choices it's not gonna come in
like 20 more times
all right our first side
september
i've never had this before i mean i've
had some garlic
seaweed yeah i think that's more like
traditional japanese style
yummy
interesting i really like it i'll try it
yeah
i have the whole thing yes
i was really thinking just a half no and
i didn't think we would even have a
whole thing because it looked like a
whole thing it didn't look like a hat i
mean you're tasting it that's not cool
that's so interesting your mouth is just
probably more
steeper yep
yes thank you so much
look at that
what is that called what is this thing
called
[Music]
all right so i got the us wagyu
udon and look how big it is
the thing's freaking crazy
that thing is huge
that is how big it is
[Music]
moment of truth moment of truth
see if joe and david did me dirty or not
that's a good rod
a nice
with some noodles
and as i was recording part i don't know
if you guys heard but she introduced my
nebayaki
udon
look at this oh after a flight i always
liked something warm and stupid i think
i got that from you which i think you
got from joe joe always get spot yeah
always and ever since then now i crave
it every time i fly so i'm excited to
try this it looks very nutritious good
look at that egg right there oh yeah
let's go
are you even eating it
yeah
is it
you yummy it
missed a little udon boy
that is the most complicated way to eat
what in the world
this guy's like eating a shoelace
yeah hook them up
there you go
cook a duty up
there we go oh yeah that's that yummy
udon
was that yummy
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
after dinner
we gotta get some shaved ice
i think we're gonna get the hawaiian
rainbow
the whole enchilada
that looks good
you want the rainbow one
no that's that's not ours that's someone
else's hey give me money what
you'll give me money
two people want money
so anytime we're in the waikiki area
in oahu we have to stop and get the
shave ice because
they use all natural flavors so this is
mango
strawberry damn what's the blue one i
forgot i remember blueberry
i don't think so
and then the mochi's uh all
uh fresh yeah and they use actual fruit
so they don't use syrup or anything like
it's
all super organic and the shave ice is
so fluffy and the environment is awesome
look at that
oh and they put condensed milk
that's candy try it
they're so used to people i love it
that's awesome
yeah and the whole environment here is
just awesome look at that and then we
got
the beautiful sun over here got the
beautiful trees
hawaii yeah leave them
hey you're spraying everyone with their
freaking ice cream juices off the spoon
okay it is yummy you're gonna do a dance
no more
you gotta do the yummy dance dude that's
true okay here comes ice cream everybody
monkey what do you see monkey
you see the ocean
hey you see the ocean this is the ocean
you made it to the beach
are you gonna monkey in the water
you gonna build a sand castle
that is beautiful
look at that over there
and just like that we made it to the
hawaiian beach today
we're gonna have some cuny times
and we'll take you on our adventures
tomorrow
see you guys